once upon a time there was a couple who
lived in a tropical paradise and every
day they enjoy a perfect life with no
hardships until one day a snake told
them to eat a curse eat fruit and
because of that God banished them from
eating once upon a time there was a
computer programmer named Tomas and
every day he worked at a big company and
got up at night to some mischiefs until
one day he met Morpheus and found out he
was living in the matrix and because of
that he had no choice but to save
mankind once upon a time there was a
farm boy named Luke and every day he did
his tours and dreamed of going to flight
school until one day his wacky robot
drove off and led him to obi-wan Kenobi
and because of that he became a Jedi
Knight today we're gonna tell you why
you want me in your next presentation
that element of drama I want to talk
about drama I don't mean flashy cars
fire overzealous teenagers know what I'm
talking about is that element of drama
you find in every good story and every
memorable movie and they all have a
common way to lay this out first
they set the scene that once upon a time
they tell you the status quo and every
day something happened but then I come
in add that tension that drama that
cools the audience in has them waiting
there on the edge of their seat for
sometimes hours listening watching until
you finally give them that resolution
so you can incorporate this drama into
your presentation because the human
brain is wired to seek it to want it one
side just craves it but the other side
will not rest until it has that
resolution so if drama you can use that
to hook your audience in capture their
attention distill that information in a
form that everyone is familiar with and
ultimately lead them with a message that
is much more memorable and much more
effective so Ross will tell you exactly
how to do this in your presentation
hopefully mr. drama William has now
motivated you to build drama into your
communication but the natural next
question you might be asking is how and
in a word you can use contrast what do I
mean by contrast what I mean is you can
make the moments of tension stand out
from the other points in your story from
the other point in your communication as
well as from all of the other things
that your audience might be used to and
I don't think you'll be surprised to
find out that contrast can come in three
general categories visual vocal and
verbal contracts and so I'll talk about
each one with visual contrast there are
several things you can do to visually
have to have you visually stand out in
that moment of drama so for example one
thing you can do is have your own
appearance stand out this is something
hopefully that you noticed from William
at the beginning of the presentation
just by the way he moved and what he was
wearing he was able to increase your
attention to that to that moment of
drama second you can have your visual
aids stand out so hopefully everybody's
familiar with the commercial in 1984 for
the Apple two and that commercial was so
powerful because it used visual contrast
on two levels first in the commercial
the the woman who throws the hammer at
big brother was set apart visually from
all of the other suit Laden zombies like
like ourselves with William in the
mercial and second the commercial itself
stood out visually from all of the other
commercials in that Super Bowl so that
people they are at the time and even now
are talking about how memorable that was
and how much their attention was grabbed
just as soon as the commercial started
there are several things you can do
vocally as well one way you can have
vocal contrast strengthen those moments
of drama is to insert more pausing and
another way is through dynamic volume so
for example once upon a time there was a
farm boy named Luke and every day
he would do his chores and dreamt of
going to flight school until one day he
followed his quirky robot and met will
be one nope so that's an example of how
potentially using volume and pausing can
heighten that moment of drama
finally verbally there are several ways
that you can structure what you say or
use different words to strengthen the
effect that tension has on how your
audience remembers and in is engaged by
these dramatic moments one example we've
actually already learned in class which
is parachuting in cutting most of the
preamble or even starting with the tense
moment so I could say face to face with
obi-wan Kenobi Luke knew his life would
never be the same yesterday on and on
and on and now you're totally engaged
what happened why is he facing obi-wan
Kenobi so that's one example another
example actually Lewis helped to show us
a few months ago and we were working
with Ken this is for cohort B he was
talking about this friend who had been
with him through all of these struggles
and he talked about this struggle and
how the friend had been with him and
that struggle and how the friend had
been with him and only at the end did he
tell us the friend was video games and
so that's an example of a delayed reveal
where we were engaged and I we still
remember that because that moment of
tension was delayed and delayed until
the end now Bryce will help show us how
he's making this work in with a real
problem he's facing right now so this is
not a drill this is an actual pitch for
my own start this is something that I'm
working on right now it's near and dear
to me and it's not an exaggeration to
say it's life or death that this pitch
is
verbal influential and persuasive and we
give you two different versions of the
pitch the first one is just going to
focus on the fats I'm gonna tell you
about the company and what it does the
second version I'm gonna take roughly
the same information and I'm gonna try
to introduce the element of drama to it
so I'd like you as the audience to be
paying attention
now the second version is different than
the first version and also like the
saying that this isn't just something
that we say that we think is
theoretically good for you I got the
feedback this morning from a professor
in the startup garage that the version
of the pitch with drama was unexpected
surprising and drew him in so these
techniques actually working we're
getting feedback that these that these
techniques can be influential so I'm
going to give you the fact version first
I'm Bryce Merida I'm a co-founder of a
company called citrine informatics and
we do Materials data materials are
everywhere even in your pocket a lot of
people are surprised to find out that
the iPhone itself which all of us or
many of us have is a marvel of materials
technology from the battery that powers
it to the cover glass that protects the
screen from scratching to the LEDs that
light up the display materials are a
critical component of many of the
products use every day and it's citrine
we're making those materials better
there was nothing wrong with that pitch
it told you a lot about what we are and
what our space is but we would argue as
a group here that you can do you can
take things to the next level by
introducing some of the elements of
drama that Ross was talking about so
here's the second version when I show
you a picture of the Apple iPhone and I
ask you to imagine what business
opportunities it presents what comes to
your mind well if you're like many
people in Silicon Valley your
imagination immediately jumps to the
device itself the hardware and all of
the amazing software you can load on it
you might talk about the smartphone
market the app market the mobile gaming
market and these are huge business
opportunities of course as those numbers
show you but the problem is that
everyone in Silicon Valley and elsewhere
in the world sees those exact same
opportunities and they're going after
them too at citrine informatics
when we look at the Apple iPhone we see
something completely different we think
materials from the lithium-ion batteries
that power the phones to the cover glass
that protects the screen from scratching
to the LEDs that light up the display
materials are an integral component of
all kinds of technologies and citrine is
using data to make those materials
better now I want to get some people
from audience about what Bryce did
differently in his second pitch any
volunteers yes
yes that's exactly right price used some
parts to create some tension about his
pitch gotcha
yes that's very true on the youth visual
contrast of the same iPhone from two
different perspectives so Infirmary a
price parachute in without preamble he
used some process to create tension
about his speech and also he used the
visual contrast of the same iPhone from
two different perspectives
he also delayed the reveal of
information and use the dynamic volume
actually you could use the same
techniques and strategies in your next
presentation or communication by
incorporating dramatic visual verbal and
virtual contracts as yawns described
earlier you could take advantage of how
human brain is wired to take to see
culture drama and this resolution to get
your message across
drama helps your audience to better
engage process and memorize your story
we are asking you to use a little bit
drama in your next presentation or
communication as we demonstrated early
this help your story to resonate better
you